[Music]  can you fight with only one arm  oh yes  if i had someone left to fight  wow  [Music]  do you really think a knife can beat a  bullet this is how people are fighting  nowadays now clean yourselves up before  this afternoon's appointment  kingsman world's finest tailor  but now we're going into the spy  business  very clever based on true events  this will not be a war of heroes  [Music]  meet history's most evil legends  their assassin gavrilo princip weakness  throwing arm  strength  started world war one  the super spy  mata hari strength  screen presence  weakness  scarves do you forget your manners  guilty as charged  have a crazed monkey  respiratory strength  and weaknesses  you'll have to see it for yourself  it's good now yes  on december 22nd our enemies think we  are gentlemen  it's time to remind them  what the kingsmen are  nobility is born  [Music]  boys are always so messy  the king's man only in theaters december  22nd  [Music]  you